Matty, with only three wins
I don’t feel safe
We have no defense
Don’t worry, Julio
after the incident
I created a state-of-the-art panic room!
Wow, I can freak out about not scoring here!
Are you always stressing
that your 30-point games aren’t enough?
You need a panic room today
I THINK I MISSED MY SUPER BOWL WINDOW
See?
Season going poorly?
Panic with us!
WE BLEW A 17-POINT LEAD?
Oh, that’s perfect. I’ll take it.
I talk a lot of s--t
but my offense f--king sucks
MOTHER
Oh, I don’t need one
My brain is sort of like my own panic room
Our rooms come equipped
with a place to tweet frustrations
a schedule to stress about
WE PLAY THE RAMS AND THE PATS?!
and podiums for you to insist
you’re not panicking at
I actually feel really good
about where we’re at
Thank you
What if I just want to give up?
Luckily for you
we have “accepted defeat” rooms
I'M NOT CRYING
YOU'RE CRYING
Each comes with a Larry Fitzgerald
to make it all better!
It’s OK if your team is garbage
as long as everyone loves you!
God, he’s so classy
So buy today!
Because the season isn’t even halfway over
Ahhh!!!